here with reaction to tonight's breaking
news chairman James Comer of the
powerful house oversight committee and
Texas Congressman chip Roy good to see
you both uh chip but we've been talking
a lot about you tonight
um it's it's it's frustrating to me I
stayed in touch with you through the
whole process you Byron Donalds Scott
Perry you know you had a two great
Alternatives you put forward
as for a continuing resolution that
would have bought time cut spending
secured the borders protected our vets
and our defense department
and those two proposals got rejected by
the conservatives here what the hell
went on
yeah Sean great to be on and great to
hear from my former boss and good friend
from Texas uh Ted Cruz and and look and
to be here with Jamie and like the the
fact of the matter is uh the Democratic
party has no interest in working with us
to solve any of the problems the
American people are facing they don't
want to solve the problem of crime in
the nation's capital that led to one of
our colleagues Democrat getting
carjacked a mere nine blocks away from
here they don't want to deal with open
borders they don't want to deal the
fentanyl pouring into Texas they don't
want to deal with you know pushing back
on China they don't want to deal with
the woke agenda killing our military
they don't want to deal with any of the
pressing issues of the day so it is left
to us to govern it is left to the 221 of
us to figure out how to get it done and
if we have some minor agreed
disagreements or even major
disagreements in our party then some of
that spills out into the open I wish we
had pursued the path of the legislation
that we put forward last week we should
have I don't know who would be against
if you're a conservative cutting 30
percent from the federal bureaucracy and
targeting border security with the
strong hr2 bill which we all work
together to pass I wish we had done that
but right now I'm Focus like a laser on
moving forward Sean we are going to
unify we're going to get through this
and come together because we've got to
go stand up for the American people to
make sure that we secure the board of
the United States cut spending make sure
we address the uh frankly the ongoing
proxy wars in Ukraine and not go down
that road very far and we've got to make
sure that we stand up for the people who
sent us here to push back on the
Democratic agenda so I'm focused like a
laser on that I'm not leaving town right
now I'm here I think we need to do our
job we shouldn't adjourn we should stay
here and do what what the American
people sent us here to do and we're not
going to be distracted from that in my
opinion I understand Steve's Steve
scalise is making calls tonight are
there any names that come to mind that
you like for speaker
I'm not going to play that game yet I
want to have some private conversations
I've I've talked to Steve and look
mainly I want him he's battling cancer I
had a blood cancer I want to make sure
he's you know healthy and good for him
and his wife Jennifer uh we'll we'll
rally around someone I assure you this
Republican conference needs to come
together and rally around and look how
this kind of thing happens
in the end this could be fine I'm not
I'm not Doom and Gloom here however the
American people's patience is going to
run out quick so I don't think you guys
have a lot of time you need to stay
there not go home lock yourselves in a
room buy pizza buy beer I don't care
what the hell you drink and come out
with a speaker that's what you need to
do so and and frankly it's got to be
somebody that's going to follow through
on the promises made Congressman Comer
I'm worried that all other action in the
house is going to stop including your
really important investigation how does
that stand
well we're going to keep moving forward
we're going to continue to read emails
we're going to continue to look at bank
statements we're going to continue to
talk to people that have Insider
knowledge of what the bidens were really
doing with respect to criminal activity
and with respect to Joe's knowledge
we're going to continue to be putting
together a timeline so we're not going
to stop we're going to continue from the
committee members standpoint from the
committee staff standpoint and we're
expecting a whole another batch of Bank
documents to come in this week from our
subpoena last week so all everything's
moving forward we're continuing to
follow the money and this is another
excellent event but it's not stopping
our work this time next week if I invite
you back well we have a new speaker chip
yes
I believe we're certainly going to work
hard to do it I mean yes okay well we
have a new speaker a week from now
yes I I certainly hope so again I don't
think we ought to leave town until we
figure that out but again these things
happen we you know this this country's
been through a lot worse we had an we
had a treasury secretary and vice
president dueling okay we're going to
get through this and we're going to make
sure that our country moves forward
secure the Border I'm not saying hold
the vine Administration accountable
you're not calling those the good old
days when we just say all right let's go
out in the back and have a duel you know
uh we're not returning to those days uh
anyway thank you both hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else